katie has given me back my life
when I got out of the Marine Corps
nobody really understood what's going on
with me from my family they loved me but
they were lost at what to do and you
don't have a platoon of Marines with you
to have your back driving in a car going
to the store all of those things are
terrible triggers those kind of
invisible scars after I came back from
the military I was diagnosed with PTSD I
really didn't like going places what you
do is you isolate it's a half life you
know
he is taught to recognize when I'm
feeling stressed he's able to pick up on
those things if I'm having a night
terror she comes and lays on my chest it
looks my face and wakes me up from that
so that's something that she's trained
to do that's good you know next time
you're about to panic it should be
comforting to have the extra weight on
you his job is to come over to me and
say hey like it's okay I'm here before
having Katie I wouldn't leave the house
if I went out it would be it like you
know midnight 1:00 o'clock in the
morning just to go shopping when no one
else is there I am working on going out
for the sake of going out he's helping
me to get over that hurdle with Katie I
know she has my back when I go to order
my coffee she'll sit there and look
behind me so I know nobody's going to
come up behind me just knowing he's
there makes a big difference things that
other people don't really realize are
happening she's doing for me so that I
can be okay with being out in the world
around other people
he had an elderly family that he lived
with and I believe that they got sick
and they weren't able to take care of
him anymore she was hit by a car and
then she got rescued like a week before
she was paired with me katie is we're so
much alike I think Katie has been
immense capacity for love the trainings
intensive you know not all dogs even
make it through so I was really really
proud when we graduated together as a
team especially to be a service dog as a
rescue to become an elite a top 1%
that's impressive
I'm very grateful to dog Chow for
spreading awareness that these different
programs exists being able to connect
with other people that are actually
going through what you're going through
is awesome Zeus has changed my life for
the better I have two little girls they
get to have their dad back my PTSD
doesn't keep them from learning how to
be happy joyful and free and there
she's not just helping me she's helping
my whole family
[Music]
[Music]